à partir du moment où on est capable de
savoir d'où l'on vient on est capable de
se voir beaucoup mieux ou encore jacques
lacoursière avait à coeur l'histoire du
québec
et c'est avec passion qu'il leur a conté
son ami éditeur l'ex-ministre de la
culture denis vaugeois souvient j'ai
pleuré j'ai pleuré parce que on est
danseur anciens depuis 1959 en 59 j'ai
dû comme étudiant avec anormal d'avoir
cette histoire histoire mais à
shawinigan dès le début des années 60
jacques lacoursière partage avec le
public son voyage dans le temps à la
radio et à la télévision
conteur extraordinaire et grand
vulgarisateur cet autodidacte va
contribuer à changer certaines
perceptions
c'est un homme qui avait le sens du
récit d'un homme qui voulait aussi une
histoire du québec rassembleuse pour
ceux qui avait décidé d'émigrer au
nouveau monde
nathan qui étaient parfois non
[Musique]
sa série épopée en amérique réalisé par
gilles carle pour télé-québec a fait
école j'ai dû un jour elle son travail
pour la série du plessis diffusée à
radio canada a marqué toute une
génération
c'est vraiment un grand communicateur un
passionné mais quelqu'un qui considérait
que l'histoire va être transmis à tout
le monde et puis nous disait toujours
une chose essayez des toniques qui on a
mangé le corps du père brébeuf jacques
lacoursière publié plus d'une vingtaine
de livres et de nombreux articles sont
l'oeuvre en cinq volumes intitulée
histoires populaires du québec s'est
écoulé à près de cent cinquante mille
exemplaires
la force de la coursière saidal est de
retourner aux sources en scindant
éventuellement des travaux existants
mais en allant plus loin les appropriant
monsieur jacques lacoursière
mais une fois récompensé le jour de son
décès à 89 ans le premier ministre du
québec lui ont rendu hommage ses
lecteurs se souviendront longtemps de
cet historien qui a si bien su préserver
la mémoire du québec
l'armée britannique vient de partir et
c'est ici que les soldats joie aux
criquets ici mais bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]